[Musique]
et j'en parlais dans les titres
informations météo la neige va encore
tomber dans les ivelines oui météo
France prévoit des phénomènes
météorologiques dangereux dans le
département dès ce soir conséquence
l'alerte orange neige et Vergl a été
déclenchée à partir de ce mardi 16
janvier 22h une alerte qui devrait être
maintenue jusqu'à jeudi matin des chutes
de neige sont notamment annoncées
mercredi on écoute ce météo ologiste de
météorance pourquoi on attend donc cet
épisode donc on a effectivement une
masse d'air froid qui donc persiste sur
le nord du pays et une dépression hène
qui donc apporte de l'air plus doux et
humide par le sud et donc ce conflit de
Mass d' va donner des précipitations
hivernales sous forme de pluiv ver
glassçante ou de neige ce qui est
important à préciser c'est que dans ce
temps bien hivernal on aura donc des
déplacements qui vont être rendus
difficiles voire dangereux c'est
pourquoi il faut bien rester très
vigilant donc pour cet épisode des
prochains jours et continuer de suivre
donc l'évolution de nos prévision on
attend donc par le sud déjà dès le le
milieu fin de soirée un premier
saoudrage de neige assez faible par
rapport à ce qu'on pourra avoir
ultérieurement en nuit de mercredi à
jeudi et puis donc ensuite ce
saupoudrage de fin de soirée va vite
être remplacé par des pluies vert
gllaçantes donc prudence pour les
Évinois face à ce saupoudrage mais on
l'a compris c'est un épisode qui
pourrait durer on aura l'occasion de
donner d'autres informations aux
ivelinois dans nos éditions prochaines
sur tv78 dans l'actualité également
Gabriel des actes antisémites qui ont
été perpétrés dans les ziliines alors
parmi les derniers épisodes en date
dimanche midi des des tags antisémites
découverts près du stade montboron c'est
à Versailles oui parmi ces tags des
signes SS de croix Celtic une étoile de
David et des slogans hostiles aux Juifs
ont été retrouvés sur une palissade
municipale passage de la abé picar pour
le moment les auteurs n'ont pas été
retrouvés des tagainux ont aussi été
retrouvés dimanche soir cette fois
c'était à viroflet deux personnes ont
été arrêté appartement toutes deux à une
mouvance d'extrême droite à garganville
une étrange histoire d'intoxication
alimentaire ça se passe dans un collège
oui tout à fait grégoryi des dizaines
d'élèves du collège Albert Camu ont été
victimes de symptômes gastriques après
avoir déjeuné à la cantine ce lundi midi
des pompiers et plusieurs équipes de
SAMU ont été dépêchés sur place pour
prendre en char les malades ils auraient
été intoxiqués avec une sauce barbecue
selon les premiers témoignages une
enquête a été ouverte on parle
maintenant de la ville de trappe le
jumelage avec la Comédie Française se
poursuit oui et c'était ce lundi un
quart de traapiste s'est rendu à la
Comédie Française pour la représentation
annuelle d'hommage à Molière un
partenariat qui va s'intensifier dans
les prochains mois les habitants
bénéficient désormais de modalités et de
tarifs privilégiés les modalités sont à
retrouver ou sur le site de la mairie le
jumelage entre les deux institutions a
pu voir le jour grâce à l'action d'Alain
Degois dit papi fondateur de la
compagnie Déclic Théâtre enfin du côté
de Rambouillet la fréquentation en 2023
du Château de Rambouillet est en hausse
oui plus de 62000 visiteurs accueillis
en 2023 c'est 9 % he de plus qu'en 2022
pour l'établissement ces chiffres
confirment l'attractivité touristique du
lieu un chiffre haut malgré un parcours
de visite amputé l'appartement de
l'empereur est enfermé pour restauration
parmi ces 62000 visiteurs près de 35 %
bénéficie de la gratuité donc les moins
de 26 ans les demandeurs d'emploi ou
encore les personnes en situation de
handicap le château confirme sa bonne
fréquentation en 2022 il comptait déjà
plus de 40 % de visiteurs par rapport à
2019 bien sûr les années covid sont
mises de côté la fréquentation ayant
chuté avec les fermetures et les
restrictions merci Gabriel vous rest
avec nous car dans un instant vous allez
nous parler de ce partenariat entre le
musée départemental Maurice Denis et le
musée d'orset à Paris et si vous aussi
he pour ces informations près de chez
vous vous êtes justement témoin d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
evvelines et n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news